C article faire ce que l'on pourrait
appeler un point de méthode concernant
la réforme du financement de l'hôpital
sur les activités dites de MCO soit un
champ qui ne pèse rien de moins que 78
milliards d'euros le gouvernement
propose une réforme dont le principe
nous convient la commission d'enquête
rapportée par Catherine de roche l'an
passé avait recommandé un modèle sur
trois piliers et les compartimentant les
compartiments pardon présentés dans
l'article 23 correspondent peu auou prou
à ce que le Sénat souhaitait le problème
n'est donc pas le schéma mais sa mise en
œuvre or sur ce point nous ne pouvons
pas adhérer à la démarche l'étude
d'impact du projet de loi est pour le
moins laconique se bordnant à un
calendrier sommaire de mise en œuvre
étalé mais aucune précision sur le champ
des activités qui vont voir leur
financement évoluer quit par exemple des
maternités ou de la pédiatrie quit de la
gériatrie la seule finalité revendiquer
de la réforme et de réduire la part de
la T2A ce qui ne peut être une fin en
soi la Cour des comptes appelé récemment
comme la commission d'enquête l'an
dernier à ne pas excessivement minorer
le rô de la T2A nous disons qu'il faut
voir activité par activité l'objectif
fixé une réforme de financement doit
soutenir une stratégie d'offre de soins
pas laaverse rien non plus sur le coût
de la réforme c'est quand même un comp
pour un projet de loi de financement
rien non plus sur l'impact financier
pour les établissements eux-mêmes vous
avez évoqué euh devant la commission
qu'il y aurait des gagnants et des
perdants sans savoir lesquels nous nous
voulons savoir les réformes de la
psychiatrie et des soins médicaux et de
le réadaptation ont montré que sur 10
ans il a fallu quasi chaque année
revenir modifier le dispositif elles ont
aussi montré les difficultés du
gouvernement pour produire des
simulations sur les effets
redistributifs c'est pourquoi la
Commission propose de préciser le
dispositif et de réaliser une réelle
évaluation avant une mise en œuvre
générale vous précipitez une réforme
pour satisfaire l'effet d'annonce du
grand de la République soyons humble
avançons de manière sérieuse ordonné et
sécurisé l'hôpital le mérite je vous
remercie merci président la parole est à
Monsieur Milon
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre la sortie du tout et deuxa
présenté comme l'idée majeure ne
signifie pas grand-chose en effet on n'a
jamais été dans un système tout et deux
a la part liée à l'activité n'ayant
représenté dans les premières années que
les 2/ers des ressources d'établissement
cette part a u au fur et à mesure que
les dépenses des listes en suus d'une
part les MIGAC d'autre part prenaient
leur place pour arriver à 59 % en 2019
la cible étant de 49 % en 2026 d'autant
que depuis 2020 les établissements ont
été placés hors T2A du fait de la mise
en place de la garantie de financement
et de la sécurisation modulée à
l'activité trois compartiments de
financement un financement à l'activité
des dotations pour des missions
spécifiques mairie aide à la
contractualisation forfait annuel
dotation populationnelle urgence et un
groupe de dotations sur objectifs de
santé publique recyclant les miges et
les firir avec un financement de qualité
issu des programmes IFAC et duucacs avec
de nouveaux objectifs de santé publique
territoriaux honnêtement incertains en
somme on reconduit monsieur le ministre
ce qui existe déjà en lui donnant une
autre dénomination l'échelle tarifaire
doit être revue les écarts entre les
grilles d' coûte et les grilles
tarifaires sont identifiés depuis
longtemps sans être résor et c'est donc
à mon avis inutile de mener des travaux
supplémentaires la Cour des comptes l'a
signalé il y a peu en particulier la
gynécologie obstétrique qui semble la
plus défavorisée les nouveautés se
trouvent dans les dotations non
programmables pour soins critiques le
principe est de mettre des financements
mixtes un socle fixe et une part à
l'activité comme le modèle T2A le
prévoyait depuis sa création en 2004
mais Monsieur le Ministre même si ces
propositions dites nouvelles de
répartition peuvent intéresser les
établissements hospitaliers le problème
essentiel vous en conviendrez c'est
celui de longondame doter les soins
critiques correctement sur quelle
activité ces montants seront-ils
prélevés madame
apursopoli merci monsieur le Président
donc l'article 23 compte évidemment
parmi les articles essentiels de ce
PLFSS puisqu'il applique l'engagement du
président de la République de réformer
la T2A qu'il avait faite en 2017 en 2018
et cette année la T2A représente
actuellement 76 % du financement en
médecine chirurgie obstétrique alors
qu'en 2018 le gouvernement avait annoncé
sa volonté de plafonner à 50 % la part
de la T2A dans le dans le financement
des établissement la question que je me
pose c'est est-ce que la sortie de la
T2A va se poursuivre où allons-nous
demeurer à cette portion de tarification
à l'activité qui baisse seulement de 57
à 49 %. si c'était la deuxième option
cela ne pourrait s'apparenter à une
sortie de la tête de a ni même à une
diversification des modes de financement
de la santé pour notre part nous pensons
que le financement de l'hôpital passe
par la fin des enveloppes fermées une
vision pluri-annuelle du des budgets de
fonctionnement
une prise en compte de l'activité
pondérée aux missions et aux besoins des
publics nous en sommes encore loin
malheureusement avec cet article 23 je
vous remercie merci Monsieur
jumier Merci monsieur le Président je
voulais à mon tour au nom de mon groupe
au moment où nous allons débuter la
discussion sur cet article
présenter la manière dont nous
l'abordons évidemment que la question de
l'â Alain a dit est essentiel on en est
tous d'accord mais une fois qu'on a dit
ça avec l'ondame tel qu'il est comment
répartit-on le financement des hôpitaux
comment financ les hôpitaux nous avons
assez réclamé une évolution du
financement
vers une baisse de la part de T2A pas
une baisse pour le plaisir de la baisse
mais une baisse pour que la T2A finance
ce qu'il est utile qu'elle finance nous
avons l'expérience maintenant de
différents modèle de financement le prix
de journée avant 1983 je crois puis la
dotation globale puis le financement
majoritairement T2A il y a pas de
système parfait mais il faut tirer les
leçons des évolutions et il faut ramener
la T2A sur les activités programmées et
cetera standardiser ce qu'on connaît et
donc l'article 23 que nous présente le
gouvernement va bien dans ce sens là
donc nous l'accueillons d'une façon qui
est positive et nous ne partageons pas
la position de la Commission qui est de
reporter ce calendrier ce sera de toute
façon une réforme longue elle va prendre
des années elle est complexe et
effectivement il y aura des gagnants et
il y aura des perdants il faut que les
gagnants soient ceux qui méritent et il
faut que les perdant soit ceux qui
actuellement sont lancés dans une course
à l'activité c'est-à-dire dans la dérive
de la T2A au prix parfois de
l'efficience et de la pertinence des
soins donc nous nous sommes prêts à
discuter de façon ouverte avec le
gouvernement pour faire avancer cette
réforme je voudrais prendre un exemple à
l'Assemblée nationale la rapporteur a
ajouter la financement par forfait de la
dialyse c'est une c'est un très bon
exemple et nous soutenons cet ajout en à
la suite de l'article 22 TER sur le
financement des forfaits de radioérapie
dans le cancer je vous remercie monsieur
le ministre
par Monsieur le Président merci mesames
et msieurs sénateurs oui nous nous
sommes là dans un des articles sans
doute les plus importants de ce projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale et qui n'est pas pardon de le
dire parce que je l'ai entendu le le
seul décalque d'une d'une volonté
présidentielle mais j'allais dire
surtout les bans de cette assemblée
comme de l'Assemblée nationale euh le le
tout et deux même si je rejoins le
sénateur Milon donc il y a il y a jamais
eu de tout et deux à euh le tout et deux
a a fait l'objet de très nombreuses
critiques et elles sont très
documentées le changement que que le
Gouvernement présente y compris par
rapport à des à des euh comment
dirais-je à une approche que nous avions
pu défendre dans le passé c'est que nous
ne présentons pas ici un modèle qui
conduirait à dire dans tous les
établissements de France on aura 48 % de
T2A x % sur la santé publique et X % sur
le recours euh ça ça avait pu être
compris comme ça dans compris ce que le
président de la République avait indiqué
non là nous disons comme l'a expliqué à
l'instant euh Bernard jaumier il y a des
activités qui correspondent bien à une
tarification
standardisée parce que quand vous êtes
une clinique de chirurgie et que vous
faites de la prothèse de la hanche euh
toute la journée la T2A reste le
meilleur système de financement
voilà deuxièmement je le dis parce que
vous êtes tous des des experts en la
matière plus que moi tout le monde a
bien en tête que quand on est à la
dotation globale ou au budget global
c'est ensuite la foire à celui qui est
le plus puissant vis-à-vis du ministère
et la variable d'ajustement c'est
souvent ceux qui sont un peu dans un
angle mort de soutien politique si je
puis m'exprimer aussi trivialement donc
je je je crois que que cette forme et y
compris l'élément que que que
j'indiquais à l'instant c'est-à-dire
celui du fait de dire c'est en fonction
de l'activité qu'on va rémunérer et ça
va donc donner des cas mix comme on dit
de tarification qui correspondent au cas
miix de l'activité de l'hôpital c'est ce
que nous voulons faire nous voulons
aussi parce que vous l'avez vous l'avez
évoqué monsieur le sénateur Milon euh il
faut pas qu'on se voit la face par
exemple les MIGAC ont été beaucoup la
variable d'ajustement sur laquelle on a
on a aidé quelques grands CHU n'est-ce
pas pour faire face donc moi je défends
la cohérence de ces de ces trois briques
je la défends d'autant plus que c'est
les trois mêmes briques et c'est pas
tout à fait un hasard que j'ai mise dans
la lettre de cadrage à l'Assurance
Maladie pour la négociation
conventionnelle avec les médecins parce
que je pense que c'est au fond le même
sujet il y a de l'activité mais il y a
aussi des activités de santé publique et
il y a aussi des activités spécifiques
de recours ça n'est pas euh je je me je
me je ne vous suis pas monsieur le
Président de la Commission sur le
terrain de dire ça sortirait de nulle
part on a évidemment très longuement
parlé avec les fédérations hospitalières
et après c'est là que l'embranchement se
fait entre l'amendement porté par euh
par la rapporteur hbert et et ce et la
et l'approche du gouvernement c'est de
dire à quel moment on on saute si je
puis dire d'abord on vérifie qu'on a un
parachute euh et puis après il faut bien
se lancer moi je considère notamment que
la perspective d'expérimentation par
région n'est pas euh y compris par
rapport au fonctionnement même de notre
système de santé et je dois dire au
principe de solidarité nationale euh
tout à fait euh pertinent on va rentrer
dans des dans des dispositifs hyper
complexes comment vous prenez en compte
les gens qui
euh de d'Alès vont faire soigner un
cancer à l'IGR ou du rôle de recours de
la PHP on va rentrer dans un truc qui me
semble extrêmement compliqué et donc il
est bien prévu on a bien devant nous 2
ans de mise en place progressive pour
une généralisation en 2026 et vous
imaginez bien qu'on a des itérations
permanentes avec avec les fédération
pour faire des simulations mais je vais
finir sur un point c'est que je je je ne
crois pas je je crois que je l'ai déjà
dit ici qu'il existe de modes de
tarification
miraculeux je pense que d'autres dans le
monde l'auraient trouvé ou sinon même
avec le le génie français l'aurait
trouvé je pense qu'à un moment ce que
vous l'avez exprimé sur le SSR ou l'APSI
ça fait maintenant 10 ans qu'on bouge
chaque année parce que on veut réduire
un truc puis on s'aperçoit qu'à l'autre
bout on fait bouger quelque chose moi ma
philosophie est un tout petit peu plus
rustique j'en conviens consistant à dire
on se donne 2 ans on lance et puis après
on corrigera s'il y a des des anomalies
un peu structurelles ou des anomalies
conjoncturelles parce qu'un
établissement parce que il a un rôle
dans un département particulier une
patientelle particulière après on
corrigera avec d'autres financements
mais je suis pour ma part convaincu de
cette philosophie globale qui fait
notamment que les établissements de
santé ne vont plus avoir peur si je puis
m'exprimer ainsi de financer des
activités essentielles par exemple la
prise en charge des femmes victime de
violence qui aujourd'hui fait l'objet
d'une Migue où pour cocher les cases de
la mig il faut avoir fait Polytechnique
deux fois ou des établissements qui
s'engagent en santé publique pour aller
faire des campagnes de prévention ou des
campagne d'aller vert donc moi je crois
que c'est important c'est important
aussi qu'on puisse laisser à tous les
état enfin aux établissements qui on la
possibilité le le le le soin d'être des
établissements de recours suffisamment
financés je dis aussi là aussi je n'ai
je n'ai pas de doute sur le fait que
cette réforme ne va pas tout d'un coup
être un coup de baguette magique mais je
pense que le report et l'expérimentation
pour moi ne sont enfin plus exactement
l'expérimentation avant un report n'est
pas l'outil par lequel on va trouver
forcément le meilleur système je moi je
crois que ces trois piliers sont solides
on a fixé et on a une méthode et les
fédérations ont validé ça fait 10 mois
qu'on travaille avec elle sur
ça vous je pense que vous en auriez
entendu parler si elles étaient vend
debout sur ce sur ce sujet voilà donc je
je je je sais pourquoi je je pense qu'on
a un gros chantier pas bordé pas pavé de
rose mais qui est une vraie réforme de
la TESA et qui n'est pas que
quantitative voilà merci monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le ministre je
suis saisi de d'un amendement de la
commission monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le Président
alors l'amendement de la commission
traduit l'expérimentation dans le texte
donc je vais pas reprendre les éléments
je simplement peut-être profiter pour
vous de nouveau vous parler de méthode
j'entends toutes les précautions
j'entends les réflexions je sais que
vous avez travaillé documenté vos
travaux bon mais ce que vous nous
proposez c'est de dire finalement on
vote la loi maintenant c'est qu'on va
tout changer maintenant pour doger
demain matin parce que vous serez pas
prêt donc on va voter modifier la loi
tout de suite pour que dès demain matin
comm on sera pas capable de l'appliquer
on va commencer par déroger et vous nous
aiquz en même temps que dans d'ici de an
si ça va pas bah on aura le temps de
changer donc on va voter la loi dans le
dur maintenant pour faire en sorte de
déroger demain et éventuellement dans 2
ans revenir en arrière ou trouver une
vre volet nous ce qu'on vous propose
c'est de mener les mêmes travaux
simplement ce qu'on vous propose c'est
un temps d'analyse et d'évaluation
pendant 3 ans pourquoi pas 2 ans on peut
le revoir mais en tous les cas et quand
les choses seront prêtes on passe en
application on traduit dans le dur
et c'est quelque part plus rassurant
pour les acteurs quand vous évoquez les
fédérations d'accord les fédérations
sont pas V de bout d'abord les
fédérations elles sont rarement vend
debout quand on parle de financement des
hôpitaux ils écoutent ils essaient de
faire en sorte quand même d'être bien
bien vu ou bien reconnu quand même mais
ce que je sais moi c'est que les
fédérations elles sont extrêmement
inquiètes inquiètes de l'évolution qui
est attendue hein mais surtout leurs
membres dans les fédérations comme on
est en enveloppe fermée qui va être
motivé pour oser bouger les lignes sans
savoir s'il va être gagnant ou perdant
aujourd'hui les les les les
établissements publics qui étaient
plutôt assez favorables se pose beaucoup
de questions puisquil mais finalement
est-ce que dans cette réforme ça va être
comme les autres réformes notamment je
pense pour un certain nombre notamment
SMR ou d'un seul coup on va se rendre
compte que certains établissements qui
pour de gagnant vont être perdant on n'a
pas les règles du jeu mais pourtant sans
règle du jeu on met dans la loi en Durre
dès aujourd'hui le fait de dire qu'on
modifie moi je suis désolé on est prêt à
vous accompagner sur les évolutions mais
vraiment dans la méthodes on on au
Parlement on n'est pas là pour
expérimenter des idées qui doivent être
traduit tout de suite on teste dans un
premier temps et ensuite et bien
lorsqu'on est tous mobilisés lorsqu'on
est convaincu de l'évolution et bien on
le traduit dans deux dans la
loi merci monsieur le
ministre je je
je merci et c'est votre votre point de
vue est extrêmement cohérent et j'ai au
sens photographique du terme le point de
vue exactement négatif c'est-à-dire si
vous regardez l'amendement parce que
quand je suis arrivé dans mes fonctions
je suis passé par le même le même étape
que vous mais si vous regardez l'AM le
le l'article tel qu'il est écrit nous ne
touchons que des mesures en L et je dois
dire que expérimenter sans l'aval du
Parlement la tarification des hôpitaux
avec que des mesures en L sans avoir eu
un débat ici je
considère que c'est un c'est un sujet et
donc oui en méthode je préfère vous
poser ici les trois principes et montrer
toutes les modifications en elle que ça
emporte dans le code de la santé
publique et ensuite vous rendre compte
régulièrement avec un objectif 2026
plutôt que de donner instruction à mes
services de travailler avec les
fédérations en vas Clo de tester des
choses qui sont des éléments totalement
structurants du mode de financement de
de l'hôpital mais j'entends tout à fait
votre raisonnement et le le le bien et
son symétrique si je puis m'exprimer
ainsiier merci monsieur le Président moi
j'entends aussi et je je partage
d'ailleurs un certain nombre de remarque
qu'a fait le qu'a fait le président de
de la Commission et y compris d'ailleurs
cette
réforme elle échappera en grande partie
au législateur la réalité c'est que dans
le détail et c'est le déta qui va faire
la réussite ou pas de la réforme qui
fera son efficience ou pas par le choix
des indicateurs c'est pas ici que ça se
passe jamais or dans ce choix-là il y
aura la qualité de la réforme et de et
l'atteintre des objectifs qui sont visés
mais en miroir de de de la position qu'a
exprimé le président de la commission je
voudrais dire que l'amendement qu'il
présente reporte tout à 2028 quel
message on envoie aux hôpitaux il
réclame unanimement qu'on revoit cette
question de la T2 encore une fois
enlevons le débat on n'est pas pour la
supprimer moi je suis d'accord avec un
Milon là-dessus il y a pas de souci mais
ils veulent cette évolution et là on va
leur dire bon B écoutez ce sera pour
2028 on est en 2023 je veux dire on on
on passe un temps
infini déjà à changer c'est normal les
process sont lourds cette réforme sera
lourde et lourde et là on veut rallonger
encore alors que le calendrier que
présente le gouvernement j'ai lu dans
dans l'amendement 260 qu'il était
précipité non nous partageons pas ce
point de vue il n'est pas il n'est pas
précipité moi je trouve que il y aura
une certaine forme de sagesse à laisser
se dérouler le calendrier qui est
proposé par le gouvernement et à retirer
cet amendement la la Commission a dit
beaucoup de choses intéressantes sur le
sujet mais ne reportons pas cette
réforme de manière excessive m
Bouin merci monsieur le Président nous
ne sommes pas non plus favorable à
repousser la date de ces changements
même très modestes et vous avez compris
que nous appelions nos vœux et pas nous
d'ailleurs seul puisque si nous ne
pensons pas qu'il faut repousser
l'échéance c'est précisément parce que
beaucoup d'acteurs revendiquent et
demandent depuis très longtemps qu'on
réforme la tarification enfin le
financement de l'hôpital et
qu'on diminue la part de la T2A voir
qu'on la supprime totalement en revanche
je rejoins le président de la commission
sur un point c'est que cette réforme se
fait à enveloppe constante et je dirais
on serait dans une situation si ce n'est
confortable au moins acceptable ça
pourrait s'entendre et je pense que les
acteurs n'y verrai pas l'ombre d'un
problème mais enfin je je vais pas
rappeler longuement puisque tout le
monde connaît la situation aujourd'hui
on a des hôpitaux qui pour la moitié
d'entre eux sont en déficit on a de très
graves problèmes d'activité pour toutes
les professions médicales au point qu'on
a des services qui sont obligés de fermé
qui a des lits qu'on aurait besoin
d'ouvrir qu'on ne peut pas ouvrir et
donc leur demander de conduire une
réforme encore une fois si modeste
soit-elle dans cette situation là ça
mériterait me
semble-t-il qu'on regarde les moyens or
vous leur proposez de de faire de tenter
de faire des économies pour encore 500
millions d'euros je crains voyez-vous
quand les mesures du segéure ont été
proposées moi je me disais bah quand
même il y a un peu d'argent sur la table
ça va donner de l'air et ça va si ce
n'est rendre euphorique les professions
médicales ils vont quand même avoir
l'impression que il y a une bouffée
d'oxygène bah c'est pas ce qui s'est
passé parce qu'il y a eu tellement
d'oubliés et cetera que ça enfin je n'ai
jamais vu prime qui suscitit autant de
mécontentement et ben là j'ai
l'impression qu'on s'en va vers une
réforme qui même modeste est quand même
attendu et que si elle se fait enveloppe
constante elle va à nouveau mécontenter
tout le monde et donc il faut faire un
geste monsieur le ministre je donne la
parole à Monsieur Milon et après madame
la
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
je j'adresse mes excuses au président de
la commission mais je ne voterai pas non
plus le le report de de de cette réforme
qui me semble extrêmement intéressante
euh pas complètement finalisée mais
extrêmement intéressante et dans votre
dans votre intervention monsieur le
ministre j'ai retenu de ou trois choses
qui particulièrement doivent être
développé la proximité dans le cadre de
la réforme et l'individualité des
établissements je pense que si si nous
allons vers ça évidemment à ce moment-l
la réforme devient passionnante mais
mais monsieur ministre parce qu'il y a
elle ne pourra se faire que s'il y a
aussi malheureusement une réforme très
approfondi du financement de la santé en
France la rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président mais je
pense qu'on est tous d'accord sur le
fait que l'hôpital va mal alors on en
connais quelques-uns qui vont bien mais
c'est pas la majorité monsieur le
ministre nous avons tous entendu dire
que la T2A n'était pas effectivement le
financement qui était le plus judicieux
même si j'entends qu'effectivement et je
le sais c'est pas le financement unique
là vous proposez à travers cet article
de changer
et on est on est tous d'accord sur ce
changement et sur le fait qu'on puisse
prendre en compte des éléments qui
mettent finalement
l'hôpital sur un aspect plus qualitatif
de leur travail c'est-à-dire des des
comment des dispositifs de santé
publique des dispositifs de coordination
des
dispositifs qui sont plus lié à la prise
en charge des situations aigues hein
c'est c'est ça finalement c'est c'est
c'est forfait élémentaire mais euh je je
ne pense pas que les choses soient aussi
simples que cela et ce qu'il manque
c'est pour ça que j'appuie totalement
l'avis de la commission c'est il manque
des choses parce que c'est un un un
ensemble et euh on on regrette qu'il n'y
ait pas dans tout cela une réflexion qui
s'attache aussi à l'investissement pour
les hôpitaux le rapport de la Cour des
comptes qui est sorti pour faire un état
des lieux de l'hôpital après la crise
covid est intéressant on sait qu'avant
la crise il y avait des problèmes de de
de d'investissement dans les hôpitaux en
tout cas que leur situation financière
était difficile en raison des
investissements qu'ils avaient pu faire
à un certain moment et qui avaient été
en fait très très lourd pour eux et puis
tu arrivé la garantie de financement qui
a finalement donné une bulle d'oxygène à
l'ensemble de de des hôpitaux en
difficulté mais après les choses ce cors
et on sait qu'un certain nombre de nos
établissements ont besoin euh de travaux
et et et parfois même d'être totalement
revu et donc il manque cette partie qui
correspond en fait à ce qu'on attend de
l'hôpital de demain c'est-à-dire la
partie investissement comment voit-on
l'investissement dans les hôpitaux
demain moi je rêve je rêve d'un ministre
vauan de l'hôpital public c'est la
réalité il faut un ministre Voban il
faut revoir l'ensemble de nos hôpitaux
sur le plan national et puis il manque
deux autres aspects c'est en fait la
régulation des dépenses comment on
interroge la performance des dépenses du
coup des recettes des hôpitaux ça c'est
très très important d'embarquer tous les
chefs d'établissement dans la recherche
de la performance et de l'efficience de
la dépense et puis le dernier aspect
c'est comment on associe les
établissements à longam ce sousobjectif
qui est donc versé vers les les les
hôpitaux mais comment on embarque
l'ensemble des professionnels de leurs
équipes dans cette recherche de mieux
dépenser et donc du du coup peut-être
d'avoir des recettes qui correspondent à
cet engagement national c'est donnant
donnant des investissements de
l'investissement mais avec aussi de
l'engagement monsieur le ministre j'ai
encore deux demandes de parole voulez
prendre maintenant ou mais non
allez-y merci monsieur le Président je
je je rassure madame la rapporteur
générale je ne pense pas un instant que
ce soit simple hein je je je je mais par
contre je de petite précision qui est
évidemment euh je ne dis pas qu'elle
répond à tout mais l'ondame hospitalier
il a progressé de 50 milliards euh
depuis depuis 2019 et euh donc à la fois
j'entends ce que vous dites euh madame
la sénatrice sur le fait que rarement
primes auront suscité euh voilà ce qui
ce qui n'est pas totalement non plus euh
incompréhensible parce que je pense que
collectivement après le covid il y a eu
un effet de de de de des compensations
Collectiv et en particulier dans
l'hôpital ce que je peux vous dire
aujourd'hui c'est que partout je et je
c'est pas pour m'en gargariser parce
qu'on est on est loin du nombre de lits
qui sont vacant faute de personnel mais
partout aujourd'hui on rouvre des lit on
rouvre des lit parce qu'on fait les
meilleures campagnes de recrutement de
depuis une dizaine d'années je je ne
encore une fois le sujet étant plutôt
celui de la fidélisation que de
l'attractivité je je ne m'en gargaris
pas deuxième point je me permets à la
rapporteur générale de dire que
j'entends ce qu'elle dit je je voudrais
bien être van mais à ce moment-là je ne
sais pas ce que la majorité sénatoriale
aurait dit à Voban lors de la l'examen
de la
LPFP
de
1688 mais en tout cas le il n'y aura pas
il ne peut pas y avoir de compensation
entre des efforts d'efficience qui sont
faits pour le coup tous les jours par
les état établissement et l'effort
majeur notamment les 19 milliards
d'euros qui sont mobilisés sur le Ségure
et qui sont je l'ai dit je le dit oui
grignoé par l'inflation et par
l'augmentation des coûts de construction
et qui donne quelquefois du
découragement parce qu'il y a des
projets qu'on avait prévu et qu'on ne
peut pas mener à bien mais je je dernier
point je ne je n'ai jamais dit que
c'était à enveloppe fermée je je ne le
dis pas parce que je ne le pense pas je
pense que si l'hôpital notamment
l'hôpital public fait plus de prévention
fait plus de santé publique je je je ne
crois pas moi qu'on fasse il y a de
l'efficience à faire il n'y a aucun
doute la garantie de financement a
quelquefois refait venir de mauvais
réflexes mais mais globalement l'hôpital
est sous tension depuis suffisamment
longtemps pour qu'il y ait pas de de
comment dirais-je de de de mamouth à
dégraisser comme disait un illustre
ministre
donc je je je ça n'est pas enveloppe
fermé notamment sur les sur les deux sur
voilà mais notamment sur évidemment sur
l'activité et puis moi je serais prêt à
revoir évidemment le le sujet des
dotations en fonction aussi des éléments
et je prends un exemple en matière de je
suis convaincu aujourd'hui que on fait
payer à londam je l'ai dit je crois hier
on fait payer à londam notamment en
matière de et à londam hospitalier en
matière de prévention
quand les quand les maternités achètent
le
bfortus ben en fait c'est de la
prévention est-ce que c'est à elle de le
payer voilà je pense qu'il y a un
chantier qui est devant nous mais mais
non on n'est pas avec une enveloppe
financière dans laquelle on redistribue
les cartes mais on va être sur cette
ligne de crête moi je vais maintenir
l'exigence d'efficience auprès des
établissements parce que cette exigence
d'efficience elle est un des facteurs de
transformation et de l'autre côté je je
suis tout à fait prêt à regarder enfin
on a la progression de la dépense elle
elle est elle est là chaque année et
après c'est sa répartition entre la
ville l'hôpital et dans les et entre
l'hôpital dans les trois branches de
l'hospitalisation donc pour moi on n'est
pas dans un jeu à somme nulle merci
Madame
souis merci monsieur le Président alors
effectivement nous non plus nous ne
sommes pas pour reculer cette échéance
de remise en cause de la T2 à l'hôpital
qui a été tellement demandé qui est une
urgence pour notre hôpital euh même si
ça ne suffit pas et même si
effectivement on a un problème
d'investissement à l'hôpital clair on
voit bien que moi j'ai pour avoir été un
petit moment au conseil de surveillance
de la php j'ai vu combien l'obligation
de vendre en fait les terrains
hospitaliers et les hôpitaux étaient là
pour pouvoir faire des les travaux
nécessaires et que ça ça devient
problématique et notre hôpital ne peut
pas devenir un une peau de chagrin c'est
donc extrêmement important que
effectivement vous dites monsieur le
ministre que il y aura une enveloppe qui
ne serait pas fermée euh nous
l'entendons j'espère que ce sera le cas
et puis deuxième point il est aussi
extrêmement important que nous puissions
avoir aussi dans cet hémicycle ou en
tout cas à la commission des affaires
sociales des points d'étape s'il y a une
expérimentation justement sur cette
question progressive de de la remise en
cause de la T2A pour que nous puissions
pouvoir peut-être ensemble évaluer et
voir comment les choses puissent aller
plus vite dans cet état d'urgence euh
que subit l'hôpital merci beaucoup mer
monsieur van
lurenberg merci monsieur le Président
euh monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je crois que on est tous
d'accord cet article 23 est important il
me paraît urgent euh d'améliorer la
situation de l'hôpital soit sur son
financement sur son fonctionnement
aussi sur le financement j'ai une
expérience j'ai été président de
l'hôpital il y a déjà pas mal d'années
j'ai vécu le système du forfait je peux
dire que si on est passé à la T2A c'est
parce que ça fonctionnait pas
bien donc on peut peut-être revenir sur
des dispositifs mais tout supprimer d'un
seul coup ça serait une
erreur et je peux je l'ai je l'ai vécu
je peux dire que c'était un peu à la
tête du client le financement au forfait
alors je sais bien quand on était du bon
côté du manche ou du gouvernement proche
du gouvernement on avait plutôt on était
plutôt bien servi quand c'était
l'inverse B il y avait des années maigr
c'était ça la
réalité et il y avait une disparité
aussi entre les hôpitaux de l'assistance
public à Paris et puis les hôpitaux de
province c'était ça aussi l'autre
réalité je vous parle de ce que j'ai
vécu donc quand on est passé à la T2A et
bien on a dit bravo et puis comme toute
réforme à ses limites on s'aperçoit
aujourd'hui qu'il faut revenir un peu
sur ce système donc le mix que vous
proposez même s'il est pas aujourd'hui
totalement défini sur des principes que
vous avez énoncé me
convient à condition d'être très proche
c'est ce que rappelait alain Milon du
terrain de vivre les réalités des
d'écouter les les directeurs d'hôpitaux
et puis les élus alors on en vient au
fonctionnement je vous ai dit il y a un
hôpital dans notre région que nous avons
pour notre part notre
groupe écouté nous avons écouté le
directeur nous avonsuditionné le
directeur c'est l'hôpital de Valencienne
fonctionne bien les finances sont
suffisantes il est dans le casadre de la
loi HPST et le management est
bon tout le monde a l'air
donc oui je sais je termine je crois que
ça aussi c'est un point important sur
lequel je voudrais insister il faut les
deux aspect pour pouvoir réussir la
réformme de
l'hôpitalésident bien merci le Président
Monsieur le Président alors pour
commencer je vrais répondre à notre
collègue qui s'inquiétait éventuellement
du suivi de l'expérimentation des
évolutions bien entendu ça sera le rôle
de la Commission de pouvoir avoir un
point d'étape sur les évolutions moi je
vrais à cet instant vous rappeler une
chose nous sommes dans un projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale et
nous avons commencé les uns et les
autres sur le B de façon quasiment
unanime nos propos en déion générale
pour parler de la sincérité des comptes
de la sincérité de long d'AM et des
perspectives financières pour 2024 et là
on est en train de débattre d'une
réforme
que d'ailleurs nous avons vu page 202 de
l'étude d'impact est écrit noir sur
blanc que cette réforme n'aura pas
d'impact financier en dehors des 12
millions pour les person person
vulnérable donc soit il yimpact
financier monsieur le ministre soit il y
en a pas mais ça ve à un moment donné si
a pas de financier ça veut dire que
l'enveloppe est constante je sais pas
lire autrement page 202 deè point vous
nous dites ben non finalement il y aura
un impact financier alors dans ce cas-là
je vous demande combien nous sommes en
loi de finance de la sécurité sociale
nous sommes pas une loi de
réorganisation de la santé donc
dites-nous aujourd'hui dans ce cas-là de
combien sera l'impact financier de cette
réforme traduction cela est-ce que la
dans ce caslà à travers ça est-ce que
cet impact financier est intégré dans
les prévisions budgétaires que vous nous
présentez aujourd'hui voilà tout
simplement donc moi je pense que je va
vous je vais vous aider monsieur le
ministre je pense que le mieux pour
pouvoir garder le cap sur l'impact
financier c'est voter notre amendement
l'expérimentation n'a pas d'impact
financier merci Monsieur le Ministre
allez-y pour pour ce monsieur le
Président et merci monsieur le Président
je
je d'abord merci d'avoir lu avec autant
de d'attention l'étude d'impact pour
être
précis 25 6 qui est la période de mise
en œuvre il n'y a pas d'impact financier
on a prévu un impact financier de 12
millions ou quelque chose comme ça
comment 12 12 c'est ça je je c'est à
partir de la mise en œuvre de la réforme
que je considère que les que les
éléments vont vont bouger mais et et ils
vont bouger aussi en fonction des
retours et j'allais dire des
démonstrateurs qu'on aura sur les
territoires qu'on a qu'on a évoqué mais
ne me le le ce que vous citez de la page
200 200 de l'étude d'impact c'est sur
2526 qui est la phase de de
démonstrateur si je puis dire voilà mais
mais mais tout ça dans une loi de
programmation des finances publiques qui
est serrée donc je ne prétends pas pour
pour être tout à fait direct je ne
prétends pas que tout que qu'on annonce
des ondes d'âes à 7 % à partir de
2027 dans le même temps pour être
extrêmement
clair merci j'ai saisi d'une demande de
Scotin public
madameon merci monsieur le Président
cela fait à peu près un quart d'heure
qu'on est en train de discuter de cet
article 23
ou même plus on a le temps c'est
sûr moi je voudrais quand même m'étonner
de la position de la
Commission parce que la demande de la
réforme de la T2A elle
date non pas de sa création mais
quasiment et c'est vrai que on a été
tous alertés par la Fédération
hospitalière de France par les
directeurs d'hôpitaux qu'on a auditionné
et qui sont plutôt favorables à une
réforme à une réorganisation de la T2A
alors certes la T2A ne couvrait pas tout
déjà hein mais en tout cas de
l'améliorer et d'avoir ces trois piliers
or la position de la Commission qui
insiste et qui
réinsiste pour demander un report de 3
ans c'est-à-dire à 2028 si on regarde
par rapport à aujourd'hui ça fait quand
même 5 ans alors que on sait dans quel
état son nos hôpitaux et les besoins de
financement qu'il y a dans nos hôpitaux
donc je crois que franchement si la
Commission veut dire qu'elle ne veut pas
de cette réforme qu'elle le dise
clairement mais je crois que aujourd'hui
on a une décision à prendre sur est-ce
qu'on écoute nos hôpitaux nos directeurs
d'hôpitaux nos présidents de CME et
qu'on va dans le sens d'une réforme qui
sera longue qui sera complexe qui sera à
améliorer certainement et en la suivant
de près mais en tout cas qui enclenche
un mouvement qui répond à quelque chose
qu'on attend depuis des
années merci
allez-y simplement pour inciter mes
collègues membres de la
majorité ici au Sénat pourquoi remettre
à demain ce que peut ce qu'on peut
commencer à faire aujourd'hui et qui a
extrêmement peu d'impact comme l'a dit
le gouvernement financier je ne
comprends pas pourquoi remettre à demain
ce que tout le monde appelle de ses vœux
à lancer aujourd'hui et qui prendra déjà
beaucoup de temps alors que déjà nos
hôpitaux sont déjà mal en point et on en
a longuement parlé il faut la réforme
progressive de la T2A je crois que ça
doit faire consensus en tout cas ici
dans cette
hémicycle
personneole chers collègues plus
personne demande la
parole voilà j'ai été saisi d'une
demande de Scotin public sur cet
amendement du groupe les
républicains le scoutin est
ouvert
personne ne demande à
voter
le scoutin est
clos votant 340 exprimé 322 pour 184
contre 138 l'amendement est
adopté deux amendements faisant l'objet
d'une discussion commune le
1362 de la Commission
bien nous allons continuer de de débat
sur la transparence financière ce qui
semble logique et donc là nous avons une
proposition à faire j'appellerai ça moi
l'amendement de la transparence des
crédits hospitaliers les objectifs de
dépense du MCO des dotations MIGAC et
des activités de psychiatrie du LSD et
des soins médicaux et de radaptation
sont définis en fonction de l'objectif
national des dépenses d'assurance
maladie ces objectifs de dépenses qui
conditionnent directement le pilotage
des dépenses de ces différentes
activités sont aujourd'hui définis par
arrêté ministériel nous
considérons convient de soumettre ces
différentes enveloppes d'encadrement des
dépenses au législateurs obligeant ainsi
le gouvernement à justifier ses montants
lors de la discussion de la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale ou à
l'occasion d'un autre projet de loi cet
amendement permet ainsi de préciser la
ventilation de longam hospitalier à des
fois à ce jour de construction plus fine
à l'intérieur de sous objectifs
je rappelle qu'en pour 2024 le
gouvernement n'a pas donné suite à la
commission qui demandait des prévisions
pour les différents ches d'activité
hospitaliers je vous rappelle également
que ça correspond à des sous-enveloppes
qui pour certaines dépassent la dizaine
de milliards d'euros voire 70 milliards
d'euros le Parlement mérite cette
discussion budgétaire voilà donc tel est
l'objet de cet
amendement merci Monsieur jumier pour le
merci monsieur le Président
donc le rapport de la Cour des Comptes
publié le mois dernier sur la
tarification à l'activité recommande des
ajustements pour une tarification plus
efficace plus équitable pardon et un
meilleur alignement avec les objectifs
de qualité des soins nous souhaitons
donc que la Haute Autorité de Santé en
tant qu'autorité publique indépendante
qui détient une expertise dans
l'évaluation des dispositifs médicaux
dans les recommandations de bonne
gestion du service de santé et dans
l'attribution de l'IFAC l'incitation
financière pour l'amélioration de la
qualité soit associé étroitement à la
définition des indicateurs et de
l'évolution de ce financement j'ajoute
que cette proposition s'inscrit
également dans la continuité des
recommandations du rapport hôpital
sortir des urgences qui a été adopté par
le Sénat en 2022 et qui préconise un
renforcement du rôle de la HAS dans
l'attribution des financements aux
établissements de santé je vous merci
merci à avis du ministre sur les deux
amendements monsieur le Président les
les deux amendements sont de nature très
très différente me semble-t-il mais mais
je me permettrai pas de m'élever
audessus de ma condition euh mais sur le
premier en fait je donne un avis
défavorable parce que je ne vois pas
comment c'est concrètement faisable euh
je comprends la je comprends le le la
proposition mais par exemple à l'heure
où nous nous parlons et où nous
examinons les objectifs de longame pour
2024 euh nous n'avons pas du tout de
stabilisé nous ne savons pas où nous
atterrissons en 23 euh et nous avons des
chiffres qui sont pas encore totalement
stabilisés pour l'exécution 22 donc le
principe de du fait de passer par
arrêter c'est de pouvoir le faire euh
hors calendrier PLFSS dès lors qu'on a
stabilisé les chiffres donc c'est c'est
plus un problème de matériel de enfin
matériel de de de comment ce ceci serait
euh réalisable donc c'est un avis
défavorable et sur l'amendement de
Bernard jaumier qui est sur un autre
champ qui est celui de d'élargir d'une
certaine manière la compétence de la HS
en l'invitant à se prononcer sur les
modalités de financement en fonction des
bonnes pratiques qu'elle aura elle-même
identifié pour le coup dans l'ordre des
facteurs faudrait-il sans doute modifier
les mission de la Haute Autorité de
Santé en tant qu'elle est une une
autorité administrative indépendante euh
mais à ce dans les conditions où nous
sommes aujourd'hui elle n'a pas cela
dans ses missions et pour ma part je
suis défavorable à à à lier à la même
autorité toute indépendante futelle le
fait d'analyser des bonnes pratiques et
de fixer le financement je pense que le
que le la distinction entre les deux
n'est pas en soi une mauvaise chose donc
c'est un avis défavorable sur les deux
amendements mais peut-être que le
président Houlier va vouloir revenir sur
le l'amendement de Monsieur jaumier
votre
avis oui monsieur le Président je
partage l'avis du ministre sur
l'amendement de notre collègue jaumier
et je me pose même d'ailleurs une
question est-ce que finalement est-ce
que c'est le rôle de HS de finalement de
s'inisser dans des choix politiques
puisque les traductions budgétaires
c'est aussi des choix politique est-ce
que c'est pas lui donner trop de trop
d'importance et peut-être ça revient
aussi le débat de l'indépendance aussi
de notre Parlement voilà donc avis dé
favorable merci je mets au voix ces deux
amendements d'abord le 1003 362 avec un
avis favorable de la commission bien sûr
et un avis défavorable du gouvernement
qui vote
pour qui vote contre l'amendement est
adopté fait tomber le
1278 je suis saisi d'un amendement et
d'un sous-amendement amendement numéro
262 de la
commission alors dans ce texte le
gouvernement a retenu un amendement
visant à inscrire la prise en charge par
forfait du traitement de l'insuffisance
rénale chronique par épuration
extra rénal pardon bon euh nous avons vu
tout à l'heure que nous avons également
évoqué euh la le le financement par
forfait du cancer par radiothérapie la
question qui projet qui est proposé
c'est d'avoir une formulation plus
générale de façon à ce que par l'ensuite
on puisse bien ouvrir cette possibilité
à d'autres prises en charge
j'entends largement évoqué de de
l'importance pour notamment la dialyse
de pouvoir être reconnu à travers cet
ément là bon voilà donc en tous les cas
on vous propose une rédaction plus
généraliste qui permettrait d'intérer et
bien d'autres prises en
charge monsieur jaumier pour le
sous-amendement oui merci monsieur le
Président moi je je regrette je je je
partage là tout ce que vient de dire le
président de la commission mais je
regrette quand même que la disposition
spécifique sur la dialyse qui a été
introduite par stéphanist l'Assemblée
nationale était retiré par la commission
enfin que la Commission propose de le
retirer alors que elle ne retire pas a
eu raison la mention du forfait en ce
qui concerne le traitement par
radiothérapie du cancer cette question
de la dialyse est une question ancienne
et je me souviens d'intervention du
président de la commission il y a
quelques années présentant des
amendements notamment sur ce qui sur la
dialse à la Réunion et cetera et cetera
voilà et là on a l'occasion je dirais
d'avancer sur la rémunération par
forfait et avec un objectif très clair
très clair c'est d'aller vers une
meilleure efficience de d'aller vers une
accélération du développement de la
greffe rénale bien que ce soit loin de
là le seul outil et on rediscutera je
pense un jour du plan Greff et de son
état d'avancement et
euh on a on a la possibilité oui de de
de développer aussi à travers
l'établissement de ce type de forfait
les méthode ambulatoire versus la
dialyse en établissement voilà donc
l'apport de de de l'Assemblée nationale
sur ce point paraît intéressant et
important et euh à l'article précédent
le vous monsieur le Président vous vous
rappeliez la nécessité d'avancer à pas
et cetera bah voilà on est exactement
dans ce cadre-là pour le coup il faut
avancer sur la question de laalise
rénale et donc le mentionner
spécifiquement dans ce texte ne pas
l'effacer je vous remercie votre avis
sur le sousamendement oui j'ai oublié un
mot je voulais simplement dire que c'est
un avis défavorable mais alors très très
réservé monsieur le ministre sur
l'amendement et le sous-amendement euh
en fait monsieur le Président merci en
fait vous avez vu tout à l'heure B
hésitation parce que le le président
Moulier avait avait présenter en fait
une partie de de de de l'amendement sur
sur dialyse et
radiothérapie moi je je je redis même si
l'amendement a été adopté avec un avis
favorable du gouvernement parce que je
suis allé trop vite pour le gouvernement
à la suite en total accord avec la
rapporteur général à l'Assemblée
nationale je pense qu'il y a deux deux
types de de d'activités qui méritent un
travail sur la forfaitisation c'est la
radiothérapie et la dialyse je pense que
ça ne fait pas de doute sur la radio
thérapie et un bon indicateur du fait
qu'on doit sans doute pouvoir avancer
par forfait c'est la financierisation de
ce secteur qui signifie queil y a de
grosses de grosses marges à faire et
donc on y va la dialyse et je ne sais
pas si c'était le la motivation initiale
de l'amendement de de de de Corine Amber
c'est un peu différent parce qu'on a à
la fois des très gros acteurs qui font
de la dialyse industriel si je puis dire
mais on a aussi dans chacun des
départements souvent des associations
qui font la dialyse à domicile qui sont
de la fédération de l'Hospital enfin qui
relève de la du privé solidaire et donc
je pense que sur la dialyse on va devoir
faire un peu plus finement si je puis
dire pour pas mettre en difficulté euh
voilà mais les deux terrains sont des
terrains théoriquement réglementaires
mais nous avions fait le choix politique
si je puis dire de le porter au niveau
du
PLFSS précisément pour montrer aussi
cette ce petit signal sur le fait que
les secteurs dans lesquels il y a de la
financiarisation ça veut dire qu'il y a
de la rente plus que du profit il y a de
la rente et donc on va voir ce qui s'y
passe et dans ces cas-là le meilleur
moyen c'est le c'est le forfait alors
ensuite sur les les les amendements moi
je considère que le le l'amendement qui
était qui était présenté que le premier
l'amendement me semble déjà me semble
déjà satisfait fait et sur sur le ce que
disait Bernard jaumier sur la la dialyse
moi je suis gêné je dois dire par la
précision de l'amendement et notamment
sur la mention de la
qualité qui en fait on le sait tous
c'est pas enfin l'association avec toute
légitimité qu'elle a Ren Lou a beaucoup
porté ce sujet-là mais là on rentre dans
un détail sur la qualité pour justifier
pour rentrer dans le forfait qui me
semble prématuré et par ailleurs on n'a
pas eu de dialogue avec les autres
associations de patients notamment de
dialysé et je pense que ce serait
indispensable donc c'est un avis
défavorable sur ce deuxè sur le
sous-amendement merci je mets au voix le
sous-amendement qui vote
pour qui vote contre le sous-amendement
est adopté je mets au voix l'amendement
bien s qui vote
pour qui vote contre
adopté l'amendement est
sousamendé
417 monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre les espqu en général et les
centres de lutte contre le cancer en
particulier relèvent pleinement du
service public de santé dans certains
territoires même les établissements
privés à but non lucratif sont les seuls
à assurer la permanence des soins de
leur côté les centres de lutte contre le
cancer jouent un rôle crucial face à
l'augmentation de l'incidence des
cancers or l'inéquité de traitement
vis-à-vis de l'hôpital public les
pénalise fortement sur le plan financier
entre le coefficient de pondération
séure et le coefficient de reprise des
allègements sociaux et fiscaux la
minoration des tarifs des centres de
lutte contre le cancer est passer de -
2,4 % en 2022 à - 2,73 % en 2023 ce qui
corr ce qui représente 39,5 million
d'euros vous imaginez facilement
l'incidence sur leurs ressources
notamment dans un contexte de tension
inédite de recrutement rappelant que les
praticiens des centre de lutte contre le
cancer n'exerce pas d'activité libérale
et que ces structures sont entièrement
consacrées au service public de santé
cet amendement vise à supprimer la
minoration de tarifs selon les
catégories
d'établissement merci avis de la
commissiono c'est vra que c'est très
compliqué mais je j'ai pas de sentiment
que l'énoncé du motif correspond à
l'amendement c'est pour ça parce que
pour moi cet amendement reviendrait à
empêcher en fin d'année le dégel
tarifaire qui permet de valoriser à
juste tarif et non pas au tarif minorés
des coefficients prudentiels voilà donc
j'ai pas le sentiment que c'est tout à
fait la même chose et donc je ne peux
être que défavorable à cet amendement
avis du
gouvernement oui je je partage l'AVE du
président il y a deux choses vous
évoquez la suppression du coefficient
prudentiel dans la dans le corps de
l'amendement et l'exposé des motifs
évoque le coefficient de minoration qui
est appliqué aux espic et à uNICANCER
j'ai eu l'occasion d'annoncer de
confirmer que nous supprimerions dans
les 2 ans en 2 ans le coefficient de
minoration mais par contre je pense
qu'il ne faut surtout pas supprimer le
coefficient enfin le la mise en réserve
prudentielle qui est qui est faite pour
toutes les pour toutes les pour tous les
établissements de santé et donc je dès
lors je en 10 ans que j'ai pris
l'engagement et que nous allons conduire
à la suppression de du coefficient de
minoration je donne un avis défavorable
à l'amendement parce que je pense qu'il
y a
une disjonction entre les les motifs et
le dispositif de de
l'amendement l'amendement est retiré je
suis saisi de trois amendements
identiques
madame Maly oui merci monsieur le
Président la revaluation du coefficient
géographique permettant de compenser les
surc supportés par les établissements de
santé de France de Corse et ultramarin
est essentiel pour le bon fonctionnement
des activités hospitalières à la Réunion
l'annonce d'une revalorisation de ce
coefficient qui passe de 31 à 34 % est
une bonne nouvelle monsieur le ministre
mais reste encore cependant à chiffrer
le montant destiné à prendre en compte
les missions non ou peu compensé par
l'État c'est-à-dire Evasan oncologie
pédiatrique allogreff
seuse mission de recours hyper
spécialisé et cetera depuis plusieurs
années tous les politiques et de tout
bord confondu ainsi que les Hospitaliers
n'ont cessé d'alerter le gouvernement
sur une actualisation de ce coefficient
afin que cette problématique ne perdure
pas le présent amendement vise à
instaurer une révision annuelle de ces
surcouts je vous
remercie merci Madame
ashliman merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre madame la reporteur
comme cela a été excellemment expliqué
par notre collègue il s'agit de demander
une fixation annuelle des coefficients
géographiques s'appliquant aux tarifs
nationaux pour les établissements
implantés en outreemre euh effectivement
il s'agit de compenser les difficultés
liées à la situation singulière de ces
territoires ultramarins insularité
salaire légaux plus élevés et aussi des
équipements peut-être une politique
d'équipement un rattrapage à faire sur
le plan de de l'équipement et de
l'entretien de l'équipement mais aussi
les produits de santé qui sont sans
doute plus élevés en raison de du du
coût de la vie chère euh je voudrais
ajouter à ce qui a été dit très
justement
précédemment que ces coefficients
n'avaient pas été revalorisés depuis
2017 pour certains territoires et en
outre à l'attention de Monsieur le
Ministre indiquer que le Président de la
République et et le Premier ministre
avaient tous les deux fait savoir qu'ils
étaient favorables à cette fixation
annuelle en 2022 j'ajoute que l'idée de
fixer annuellement ces coefficients
géographiques permettent de faire
d'assurer un suivi de de la situation
pour ces territoires ultramarins qui ont
des difficultés particulières mais aussi
cela ne veut pas dire que ça sera une
revalorisation annuelle donc cette
précision est sans doute de nature à
rassurer sur les intentions parce
qu'évidemment l'idée c'est de ne pas
donner moins de services en terme
d'accès à la santé aux territoires ult
ultramarins mais nous devons aussi
prendre en compte les difficultés
financières que que l'État peut
rencontrer dans cette gestion merci
merci c'est Monsieur
est défendu
ahy merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre alors je voudrais expliciter
cet amendement avec une situation que je
connais bien qui est donc celle de la
Réunion et et je voudrais dire qu'après
de longues années d'attente et nous
parlons de plus 10 ans suite au
mouvement de grève des hospitaliers
ronnais et à la mobilisation de
plusieurs politiques un accord a enfin
été trouvé afin de revaloriser le
coefficient géographique pour le calcul
des dotations
effectivement cependant ce déficients
géographique ayant pour intérêt de
compenser les surcûts des établissements
de santé rignonné on l'a dit ne peut
rester figé et être à chaque fois résolu
par des conflits ou de longues
négociations le CHU de la Réunion accuse
aujourd'hui un déficit de 50 millions
d'euros dont plus de 2 tiers sont
imputables à un trop faible coefficient
géographique et à la non compensation
des mesures liées aux Ségur n'oublions
pas que 70 % du déficit est imputable à
l'état nous avons obtenu trois points
alors même que le rapport indépendant de
2018 appelé à 4 points le FHF parle même
de 8 points sur une année le temps d'y
voir plus clair par ailleurs véritable
établissement de référence du sud-ouest
de l'océan Indien le CHU de la Réunion
accueille de plus en plus d'évacuations
sanitaires depuis sa création auparavant
400 aujourd'hui on parle de 1600 et
rappelons que lorsque la spécialisation
des soins ne peut se référer au CHU de
la Réunion et bien le transport aérien
des patients c'est aussi l'augmentation
du taux de mortalité mais c'est un état
de faite et on on doit l'accepter mais
nous avons besoin que cet hôpital public
rev clairement fièrement financièrement
et matériellement son référencement
unique au sein de l'osson indien tous
les Français étrangers de la zone Osson
indien viennent s'y faire soigner cet
amendement vise donc à protéger
anticiper les lourdes difficultés de
l'hôpital public dans les outr-mers des
situations catastrophiques qui
interpellent encore lorsque l'on sait
que les effectifs travaille sous
pression lorsque l'on considère le
nombre important d'emplois précaires
lorsqu'on nous explique de l'absence de
F fidélisation du personnel soignant et
oui il préfèr parfois démissionner voir
changer de carrière tellement
l'expérience a été mauvaise lorsque l'on
considère également et sincèrement parce
que l'on sait tout et tous qu'un hôpital
sous pression signifie également la
multiplication des risque de
maltraitance envers les malades les
hôpitaux publics des outres mèes ont
besoin de stabilité monsieur le
Président et nous devons penser à la
qualité des soins et non pas à la
continuité des soins en mode dégraté
nous sommes la vitrine de la République
merci chers collèg
merci l'avis de la commission pour sur
ces trois
amendements alors l'avis de la
commission est favorable sur justement
la volonté de d'avoir une annulisation
et donc une vision plus précise mais par
contre je profite de cette réponse
courte pour poser une question au
ministre c'est que on vient d'évoquer la
réforme de la T2 quel impact notamment
sur les coefficients géographiques don
sont directement concernés les les teres
TR les département du tromè monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs je
prends quelques instants sur le
coefficient
géographique pourquoi parce que
évidemment dès que j'ai pris mes
fonctions j'ai j'ai pu mesurer la la
vigueur de de l'interpellation sur ces
sujets que j'avais croisé également dans
mes fonctions précédentes j'ai donc
demander à la l'adresse enfin la
direction de la statistique du ministère
de revérifier de re challenger nos
propres nos propres hypothèses sur le
coefficient géographique c'était un
sujet dont j'ai pu parler par exemple
avec la présidente hugette Bellot il y a
quelques mois quand elle était venue me
voir les conclusions de l'étude
d'urgence que j'ai demandé à la à
l'adresse ont conduit le gouvernement à
décider non pas après un conflit social
mais a décidé d'une revalorisation
progressive pour les départements dont
il est avéré qu'il y a un retard cette
évolution ne va faire que des gagnants
même si tous les territoires ne le
seront pas je veux dire et c'était bien
sûr essentiel qu'il n'y a aucun perdant
à titre d'exemple et je m'adresse
évidemment tout particulièrement à la
sénatrice
bellim et à la sénatrice mé le
coefficient géographique de la Réunion
augmentera à la Réunion dès 2024 à la
Guadeloupe comme dans d'autres
territoires et je m'adresse à la
sénatrice nadille et à notre président
du jour le coefficient géographite le
coefficient géographique restera stable
je connais l'attachement du Sénat à la
recherche d'amélioration constante de la
prise en charge des spécificité
ultramarine et je salue bien évidemment
en ce sens les les prises de position
des uns et des autres et notamment de de
Dominique
Théophile je voudrais dire aussi que
évidemment bien au-delà du seul
coefficient géographique il y a beaucoup
d'autres mesures qui doivent prendre en
compte la spécificité des territoires
ultramarins je redonne quelques exemples
parce que pour les les sénateurs
métropolitains vous vous verrez le le
enfin comment dirais- je ce n'est pas
c'est c'est justifié donc je je voilà
les c'est le Ségure de la santé à
conduire a débloqué 759 millions d'euros
en Guadeloupe dont 580 pour la
reconstruction du chut de Guadeloupe qui
est pris et qui est financé à 100 % par
l'État sans donc emprunt 448 millions
d'euros en Martinique 274 millions à la
Réunion et 67 millions d'euros à Mayot
et permettez-moi ici d'avoir une pensée
absolument enfin très très particulière
pour les professionnels de santé de maot
qui font face à une situation extrême
difficile par contre je ne partage pas
madame la sénatrice la propos enfin j'ai
met un avis défavorable sur la
proposition
d'annualisation pour plusieurs raisons
la première telle que rédigé
l'amendement part du principe qu' y a il
n aurait que la FHF à consulter mais bon
ça je je mets ce point de de côté moi je
crois que le coefficient géographique
c'est un élément qui doit être
structurant pour la construction y
compris pluri-annuelle et la visibilité
pluriannuelle pour les les
établissements et si on part du principe
qu'on le révise chaque année au-delà de
l'extrême lourdeur on peut considérer
que c'est un argument techno mais c'est
un l'extrême lourdeur pour faire tourner
les machines et trouver le bon niveau de
coefficient géographique ça crée une
remise en cause chaque année dans
l'élaboration du budget en fonction du
niveau du coefficient géographique moi
je pense par contre évidemment qu'il y a
d'autres mesures de soutien ponctuel et
on le fait évidemment chaque année
notamment en trésorerie pour les
établissements qui là doit va être revu
et objectivé chaque année et pour le
coefficient géographique je pense plutôt
que le travail qui a été conduit doit
nous permettre d'avoir de la visibilité
sur plusieurs années et de permettre aux
établissements y compris de projeter
leurs recettes stables venant de la
prise en compte des spécificités
ultramarines dans la durée et juste sur
la réunion je vrais souligner que le le
point qui a été soulevé notamment le
conflit social Fadila catabi la ministre
délégué au près d'Aurore berger était à
la Réunion il y a quelques jours elle a
rencontré euh plusieurs les équipes de
de de de l'hôpital et nous allons et
nous travaillons et je travaille en ce
moment même avec l' RS pour trouver des
des réponses je je conçois ce que vous
dites mais sur le fait qu'il y a des
mouvements sociaux qui conduisent la la
mobilisation en l'espèce ça n'est pas
eux qui ont conduit à la révision du
coefficient géographique mais il y a ce
sujet particulier qui n'est pas neutre
qui pèse sur la Réunion qui pèse encore
plus sur la Réunion vu la situation à
Mayotte et donc on est je je je vous
vous assure que nous travaillons dessus
particulièrement
merci allez-y explication de vote merci
monsieur le Président moi je voudrais
juste rappeler que nous permettre une
révision annuelle ne forcément ne va pas
forcément indiquer une une augmentation
c'est juste créer une stabilité une
sécurité pour ces territoires il est
juste question et bien de santé publique
pour les territoires d'outrem il est
question de qualité de soins et encore
une fois ils n'ont pas de continuité de
soins en mode dégradé et et si l'on a la
possibilité donc d'ouvrir une révision
annuelle on a la possibilité peut-être
d'anticiper des situations désastreuses
c'est tout simplement
cela merci je vais mettre au voix ces
amendements avis favorable de la
commission défavorable du gouvernement
qui vote
pour qui vote contre les amendements
adoptés amendement 263 de la commission
monsieur c'est une correction d'une
erreur matérielle avis de la du ministre
je mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote contre qui s'abstient
amendement adopté amendement numéro 30
monsieur
Milan merci monsieur le Président le 20
bulle du Grandin de l'article 23 propose
des modifications à apporter à l'article
l162-2-19 du code de la sécurité sociale
relatif au financement de la psychiatrie
or la mise en œuvre de la réforme du
financement des activités psychiatrie a
fait la démonstration depuis 2020 de
l'insuffisance des dispositions
législatives qui lui sont consacré
seulement deux articles dans le code de
la santé de la sécurité sociale et du
caractère parfois inapproprié de
nombreuses dispositions réglementaires
prises pour leur application parmi
celles-ci figure l'encadrement trop peu
contraignant du pouvoir réglementaire en
ce qui concerne le compartement financé
par le biais de la dotation
populationnelle dans le secteur de la
psychiatrie afin d'y remédier le présent
amendement sur le modèle de ce qui
existe déjà dans les dispositions du
Code de Santé publique c'est l'article
l14
35-10 pour l'utilisation des dotations
du fond d'intervention régionale propose
la remise d'un bilan annuel qui Dre
évidemment le bilan d'utilisation de la
dotation populationnelle dans le domaine
des activités de psychiatrie de cette
manière les objectifs assignés par le
législateur à cette nouvelle modalité de
financement pourront être annuellement
contrôlé par le Parlement commission
comm c'est une demande de rapport ser un
avis défavorable avis du gouvernement
même avis défavorable je mets au voix
l'amendement avec deux avis défavorables
qui vote
pour qui vote
contre
adopté
1279 monsieur le président loi prévoit
que le gouvernement remette au Parlement
avant le 15 septembre de chaque année un
rapport sur le financement des
établissements de santé et notamment ce
rapport doit convenir doit contenir
pardon les perspectives d'évolution de
ces financements donc il nous paraî pas
nécessaire et même légitime d'annuler ce
rapport comme le souhaite le
gouvernement c'est pour ça que nous
avons présenté cet amendement de
suppression de l'alinéa 105 je vous
remercie avis de la commission
alors cet amendement vise à supprimer
l'abrogation de dispositions codifié
prévoillant un rapport annuel sur la
situation financière desétablissement de
santé alors que l'annexe 6 Opel FSS
porte précisément sur ce sujet il
n'apparaît pas ce table de maintenir ce
rapport satisfait par la loi
organique on pourrait en revanche
discuter de l'accessibilité de cet
annexe de son format alors que la la la
loi de finance prévoit un format
aisément exploitable les données
chiffrées ne sont pas mis à disposition
d' des conditions satisfaisantees pour
le contrôle parlementaire donc j'en
profite pour porter ce message donc avis
défavorable monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président effectivement je
je l'annexe 6 du projet de loi en
prenant en compte la remarque du
président sur laquelle je vais me me
pencher le le le le l'annexe 6 du projet
plan de financement de la sécurité
sociale doit permettre d'éclairer le
Parlement sur les actions menées dans le
champ avec un dans le champ du
financement des établissements avec un
bilan rétrospective et les évolutions
envisagées je pense qu'elle est même
plus large que le rapport annuel
précédent et donc je considère que le
nous n'y perdons rien en supprimant le
rapport puisque l'annexe 6 modulo le
Kavat fait par le le le président et
satisfait à cette demande donc je je
donne un vite
défavoraable monsieur jumier moi je
voudrais demander à monsieur le ministre
c'est parce que l'état de l'annexe 6 euh
fait que on n lira pas dedans je vois
pas comment les évolutions liées à la
réforme que nous avons pour notre part
nous approuvons sur le mode de
financement des hôpitaux si le si
Monsieur le Ministre me dit que l'annexe
6 va être transformé et qu'on pourra
suivre à partir de cet annexe 6 ces
évolutions les évolutions de la T2A la
montée en gamme des des autres dotations
à ce moment-là je retire l'amendement
mais voilà faut que ce soit clair l'exe
6 doit être transformé le le euh vous
avez à ce moment-là soyons clair en
effet l'annexe 6 doit être exploitable
pour suivre les évolutions législative
que que le législateur approuvera ou qui
seront considérés comme adoptés euh euh
donc oui on va retravailler cette annexe
6 spécifiquement sur le point que vous
évoquez euh la précision est utile euh
et donc je pense que c'est nécessaire et
ça complète celle que donnait le
président le retirz monsieur il est
retiré
amendement 264 de la
commission une un amendement
rédactionnel monsieur le ministre je
mets au voix qui vote
pour contre abstention il est
adopté deux amendements
identiques présente monsieur
Milon
merci monsieur le Président je vais être
court le présent amendement vise à
maintenir de manière transitoire
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2024 les modalités
actuelles de financement des
établissements privés de smmr le temps
d'appréhender de faire évoluer
efficacement les conditions de bascule
vers la nouvelle facturation cet
amendement permet d'accompagner la
réforme du financement SMR sans remettre
en cause évidemment son entrée en
vigueur il apporte de la souplesse aux
acteurs qui conservent une base de
référence historique sans présenter de
coûts supplémentaires pour les finances
publiques monsieur fialer est défendu je
mets l'avis du de la commission
oui l'avis de la commission cet
amendement conduirait à reporter une
réforme qui à la demande notamment de
notre commission est entré en vigueur au
1er juillet dernier le débat avait été
difficile au Sénat sur ce point le
gouvernement joue en stop and go sur
cette réforme à chaque pfss depuis 3 ans
avec des amendements de dernièrees
minute cette réforme se met en uvre
difficilement nous nous savons un retour
un arrière ne sent pas pertinent nous
avons soutenu cette réforme elle doit se
mettre en œuvre la Commission entend
d'être cohérente et c'est pourquoi la
viis est défavorable avis du
gouvernement je me lève parce que sinon
on est battu quand on se lève pas sur
les amendements du sénateur Milon donc
je je au cas où euh donc non mais euh
voilà c'est c'est c'est non je suis pas
supersticieux ça porte malheur donc du
coup euh non je je de le je je ne à la
dire je partage ce que vient de dire le
président de la commission et je me suis
posé la question si vous considériez que
les établissements de santé ex auqn
n'étit pas encore rentrés dans cette
réforme or ils sont eux aussi déjà
rentrés donc ça voudrait dire qu'on
revient également pour eux en arrière
donc c'est un avis défavorable comme
celui de de de la du président de la
commission amendements avec deux avis
défavorables qui vote
pour
qui vote contre il sont pas
adoptés monsieur fialer pour non c'est
Madame merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur monsieur le ministre cet
amendement porte également sur la
réforme du financement des soins
médicaux de réadaptation cette fois pour
les établissements publics très attendu
cette réforme permet de mettre fin à la
dualité des modes de financement entre
la dotation annuelle de financement et
les prix de journée qui aboutissait à un
sous-financement chronique des
établissements publics malheureusement
la réforme entrée en vigueur en juillet
se traduirait au terme de la période de
transition par un impact négatif sur les
ressources du secteur public hospitalier
50 % des établissements publics dont 60
% des CHU seraiit perdant pour un coût
estimé à 36 millions d'euros soit 1 % de
leurs ressources actuelles il apparaît
donc nécessaire de prendre le temps pour
sécuriser la réformes corriger les
imperfections techniques et donc faire
des ajustements nécessaires cet
amendement sollicite cite donc un
allongement de la période de transition
de 2 ans jusqu'en 2028 pour que les
établissements publics puissent
continuer dans cet intervalle à utiliser
le modèle de financement
actuel avis de la
commission monsieur président merci je
comprends tout à fait les préoccupations
de de l'auteur de de l'amendement et des
cignataires on a évoqué hein la
difficulté de la mise en place de cette
réforme quoi qu'il en soit le la période
de transition est déjà calé jusqu'en
2026 et donc pourévoir tout de suite le
prologer jusqu'en 2028 me semble voilà d
donc attendons déjà on en rediscutera
mais ça me semble un petit peu prématuré
voilà donc avis défavorable avis du
gouvernement
oui la vie est défavorable à fortuie
parce que la période de transition est
jusqu'au 31 décembre
2027 donc le le il y a quand même le
temps d'adapter amendement voit avec
deux avis défavorables qui vote
pour qui vote contre il n'est pas
adopté
265 amendements de la commission
oui en cohérence avec la position de la
Commission où nous avons mis en place
l'expérimentation he pour l'évolution de
de la T2A donc c'est un amendement vise
à reporter au 1er janvier 2028 la
réforme du financement du MCO et la
préservation jusqu'à la fin de l'année
2025 du mécanisme de sécurisation
modulée à l'activité
avis du
gouvernement un avis défavorable mais je
crois que les les les arguments ont déjà
été échangés tout à l'heure je mets au
voix l'amendement qui vote
pour qui votre
compte il est adopté je mets au voix
l'article 23 qui vote
pour qui vote contre qui s'abstient
l'article 23 est
adopté après l'article 23 un amendement
26 rectifi qu TER monsieur
milonalif c'est moi qui remplace Milon
pour soulager monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président Monsieur
monsieur le ministre ch collè